Eggs come in a variety of colours -- white,
brown, blue, green, and speckled.
The difference in shell pigmentation is superficial,
but the reasons are genetic and evolutionary,
dating all the way back to dinosaurs.
Let’s start with the familiar white and
brown chicken eggs.
You might have a preference, but one doesn’t
have more protein or a better taste than the
other, though brown eggs tend to have slightly
more Omega-3 fatty acids.
Brown eggs also come from larger chickens
that cost more to maintain, which is why those
eggs are a little more expensive.
It’s not because they’re way better.
Brown eggs get their color from a biochemical
pigment called protoporphyrin formed by blood
cells breaking down.
And of course biochemical pigments are due
to genetics.
White-feathered chickens with white earlobes
called Leghorn chickens lay white eggs while
one type of red or brown chickens with red
earlobes called Orpingtons lay brown eggs.
But, it gets weirder.
The Ameraucana breed lays blue eggs, giving
it the nickname of the Easter egg chicken.
Olive Eggers, a cross between a hen and rooster
that are from a brown egg and a blue egg laying
breed, lays olive green eggs.
In each case, the pigment is deposited on
the egg as it moves through the hen’s oviduct,
fairly late in the shell-forming process -- the
last 3 to 6 hours of a 20 to 26 hour process
-- so the color doesn’t actually pass through
the shell.
If you look at the inside of the shell of
a brown egg after you crack it, the inside
is white, not brown like the outside.
But aside from genetics, there are other factors
that can influence an individual egg’s pigment.
A bigger egg would need more pigment to cover
it, so if the hen only releases a set amount,
that egg can be lighter.
An older hen will generally lay lighter eggs.
The egg can rotate as it moves through the
hen, too, meaning pigment can be unevenly
distributed.
Stress on the hen can lead to less pigment
and a lighter egg as well.
As for the more interesting colors we see,
such as the blue eggs, the color comes from
a pigment called oocyanin, a by-product of
bile production.
But there's an evolutionary advantage to blue
eggs, since birds like robins and emus lay
their eggs in an open nest.
The blue pigment filters out UV light, protecting
the egg from sunlight and stopping it from
overheating.
The darker blue eggs are generally found in
environments where there’s less direct sunlight;
the darker pigment absorbs more sunlight to
warm the egg.
Speckled eggs, meanwhile, have inherent protection
from predators, offering a bit of camouflage
while they sit in a nest.
This explains why other egg-laying animals
lay unpigmented eggs, like turtles.
Turtles bury their eggs in a protected nest
so don’t need the UV protection or camouflage.
This all has led scientist to conclude that
egg colours came about around the time that
species starting laying eggs in uncovered
nests rather than bury them, something dinosaurs
species like Ovirapt--- like these were known
to do.
So which ever eggs you choose to buy, you’re
making an egg-cellent choice.
For more science content be sure to subscribe
to seeker!
Speaking of dinosaur eggs, Trace can tell
you what we can learn from them in this video
right here.
Thanks for sticking around till the end!
Speaking of sticking and egg colours, fish
eggs are coloured depending on the female,
not the species!